two hours three hours once I'm I'm
spending like six hours a day on it
it's happening
Christian what's more fun for you
writing your screenplays or reading them
[Laughter]
I don't sometimes I don't even know if I
like writing my screenplays I I
I'm usually starting a screenplay sucks
uh Brad part usually sucks
when you get in the zone oh yeah that's
it
Zone of writing a script
um that's when it gets really you you
get jonesed that means that you actually
enjoy uh waking up at um seven to eight
a.m even sometimes earlier
um like around six and you put on the
coffee and sit down in front of the
computer and and keep keep moving it
Forward because you're you're confident
as to where all the pieces fit and where
where you're going and even if you're
not confident you know that you're it's
like you're getting in the car again
after a pit stop
um running the Le Mans and you're and
you you know you're going to win the
race if you if as long as you you know
keep the lug bolts on the on the tires
so so
that's that's that's when it's fun but
sometimes it takes a while to get to
that place I do realize that
um for some people it never is fun
um in the process it's it's it you can
be slogging it out quite a bit and I do
recall when it was for me it was never
fun writing it
um until I got to the to the second
draft
you know until I got to rewriting then
I'd go oh wait no this is no this is not
that bad
[Laughter]
I feel like I was like digging through
you know a pile of trash that I'm
salvaging some articles that didn't need
to be thrown away but but
yeah
that's that's when for me
um now that it gets fun
um
I
don't take any particular pride out of
reading anything
I've written
I don't
it's I don't know I guess it's sort of
like like watching yourself on screen
you know
um which is a meta thing to say as this
is occurring
um I I don't I I I don't think I I it
doesn't occur to me to want to read
anything I've written you know
um other than to check it for mistakes
or errors and to you know to make sure
that it aligns properly in accordance to
to structure and um and you know that
sort of thing
so writing the first draft at times can
be it sounds like energizing but at
other times not
well I mean it's energizing when you're
like I said when you're in the zone so
the meaning like
so
you start writing
and
for me
and I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna preface this
by saying because you referenced this
before we we start talking about the
debate of of outlining and when I was uh
when I was a kid or when I was younger I
should say
um I did quite a bit of outlining and I
learned a specific method
on how to outline from some very
reputable folks
and I've abandoned them entirely I don't
recommend that to anyone
um if um if somebody's new writing
um outlining is absolutely essential in
my mind I know people have differing
opinions about that but it's absolutely
essential but I do think that once you
have a grasp of what you're doing that
you can feel absolutely free to get get
rid of it when you're ready when you
find your voice
um there there's you know there's a
thing it's like it's like um you know
it's like the
Picasso analogy you know it's like it's
like once you know the rules you can
throw them away you know Picasso was a
fine uh naturalistic painter
at age 10.
okay
age ten all right
by the time he's in his early 20s he can
start to experiment a little you know so
thing
um applies
um to um
to screenwriting I believe so
for me
um I start a script and I have like a
satellite number of notes those notes
are usually jotted down in on something
these days they're in my phone I um I I
I use the note field and I throw little
ideas in there sometimes bits of
dialogue and things like that when they
accumulate to a point and there's a
number of these going on at once I mean
a number of story ideas when they
accumulate to a point I open up a
a a file on my um
my computer and I start
um I start stringing those notes
together
once though I start stringing those
notes together I'll transfer those to a
final draft file and I'll start spacing
them out
like I'm piecing together a puzzle like
um like um you know you take a puzzle
and you start with the edges first
you know I will go oh this might go like
around here in the story and this might
go around here in the story and this
might go around here and then I
repeatedly return to that final draft
file
and stare at it and go let's put
something in here and let's put
something in there and let's put
something in here
and continually build it based on that
rubric
and then when it starts to become
something fulsome
and it
I start to get energized by it
I might spend more time on it so like
two hours three hours once I'm I'm
spending like six hours a day on it
it's happening
you know I'm I'm I'm at that point I'm
in the zone
and I'm just I'm I'm like
forgetting sometimes to get lunch
because I'm so
um
and I'm so wrapped up in the story
there you go